[Música]
e aí galera que a gente vai tornar tudo
com vocês ela tem que falar baixo porque
são só uma hora da manhã e se você dá
assistência devida porque provavelmente
o desafio da minha cirurgia de garganta
e não podendo gravar então deixe ele
guiava porque eu sou moleque daí é só
pra cá veio eu sou o que sou que não
tinha apenas a nova loja vai cair na
minha casa contou com 50 lento e miojo
do esporte dias a dinha pó que havia
antes eu sou muito a organização eu pedi
à minha página no meu facebook que vocês
perguntarem coisa sobre escola então se
você não curte a minha página no
facebook ou seja provavelmente deve ter
perdido essas perguntas não conseguiu
responder mas eu vou fazer uns com
certeza o conceito e não fazer um dos
filhos quando ele pergunta para você
ficar de fora do pt é o primeiro link na
descrição do vídeo à minha página do
facebook vai lá e curtir a página do
instituto final é muito tudo estiver de
novo tudo santo amaro - aí eu fui lá na
minha página no facebook o pedido às
pessoas a entrar as coisas sobre escola
e hoje eu vou responder à primeira
pergunta sendo bem no seu evento porque
é de 14 antigamente não tinham feito vai
ser até uma coisa que ele conversar com
você eu não sei o que acontece hoje em
dia que parece a mãe tá tomando o e
pronto em no útero amanhã com 3 14 ana
com peito bunda país que tomam uma
mamadeira de um erro crasso apresentou
problemas em atuar estupro pedofilia a
mas eu não sabia que ela não quer a
pedofilia pois apenas 18 19 anos gente
tem que olhar a identidade hoje podia a
oportunidade de mais nada é como
acreditar quem vê cara não vê o que deus
ajuda quando seu madruga
a segunda pergunta da stefhany luana
porque mal chegamos na escola já
querendo sair de lá steph no querido
quer um ex colo que é bênção às aulas a
escola é boa gente vai lá e ver os
amigos tudo bem eu como é que está todo
mundo contra uma base do que está a
acontecer acho que o professor
vamos lá tomar todo mundo bem no seu
livro na página 14 a tarefa exige está
plenamente castán pronto futebol por
isso que a gente quer sair é a pouco a
gente se forma o chapéu pra cima mais
desgraça para estudar mais falada estudo
perguntou já aconteceu de você se sente
à vontade para a escola só que estava
gostando de uma mina ou acontecer de
mais de uma vez que era apaixonado pela
menina ela até miami agora é a carol era
tão apaixonado é tão apaixonado pela
personal de manhã cheguei a entrar
meio-dia meio dia avançava já queria
dormir para passar o dia ao acordar só
no japão a escola vélodrome se é tão
amorosa e sexual a pessoa de sua vida
você fica com ela porque a pessoa quer
assistir aula de matemática de física e
de química só pra te ver porque ama de
verdade a mariana feliz tentou porque
90% dos professores adoram falar da vida
pessoal deles mariano de conseguir
professor também já foi aluno e ele sabe
como é ser ruim ele sabe como é sofrer
ele se formou ele está vivendo vocês
sofrem é fácil participar da [ __ ] não
sou feito tudo que eu sou filho eu vou
falar de todos roller que eu fui para
identificar a nata momento nenhum agora
também foi também possa sair para a
mulher não tem que estudar mas ele pode
ele jogasse na sua tarefa é isso a
mariana trilheiro perguntou por que não
podemos atrasar a entrega ao trabalho
eles podem atrasar a entregar pro
mariano minha filha você pode atrasar o
seu trabalho ele pode tratar a entregar
porque não pode atrasar sua menstruação
cantar o paulo victor de almeida
perguntou por que razão para acabar os
estudos e quando acaba a gente quer
voltar a estudar na verdade você não
quer voltar a estudar você quer ir pra
escola onde estão seus amigos não onde
estão seus professores ea gente tem onde
tem azar você quer ver a galera
a leroy ó meu normal eu vi naquela rua
tiago está perguntando porque nas
escolas têm mais [ __ ] que nos porteiro
não anda você tem a minha escola não tem
mais pontos que disputei na escola tem
mais projectos tipo ali é uma [ __ ] está
nascendo ali é ovário da mãe porque ele
está aprendendo a ser pelo avandia meu
peitinho na sesap não anda fácil também
alemã ainda está aprendendo a ler você
quer que eu pensei na costa na cena
pública nem além disso é perguntou por
que a gente chama a merendeira de dia o
que toda a madeira que se preze tem cara
de tias e nunca chegaram a merendeira
que tem cara de sobrinho e pegar de
madrid não tem só tentar de tia alex
silva perguntou se já tentou fazê lo do
banheiro aparecer
oi eu confesso que eu tentei fazer
aparecer só quando eu falei a segunda
vez já não é melhor não acho que não é o
josé e bauru o que fazer quando você
solta um pum na saúde ao já é o seguinte
você tem que fazer é não está sozinho
porque o que seria do peru se não
existisse uma pessoa preocupada então 60
do lado de alguém você perde faz isso
a finma etapas gente tá ponte ó 11 né
não
até sair daqui a atriz se ela perguntou
por que a escola sempre tem aqueles
professores paradão na verdade não tem
aí já vem aquela toda história que
acontece no começo que é o projeto e
[ __ ] com a minha de 14 anos que tem
feito agora tá fazendo cosplay da [ __ ]
né está fazendo o telecurso 2000 e como
se a [ __ ] ela vem gostosa e pronto o
professor que é homem já caiu na tarde
só rafael silva perguntou por que
existem trouxas que pergunta se pode
fazer dupla de três na verdade não é
trouxa que quer fazer não pode ter na
verdade é que aquele cara que quer ser
engraçado na turma com a galera o
trabalho de dunga como professor pode
fazer o dono de três copas
sou muito resolve gostou da perguntou
por que você nunca carga na escola que é
o seguinte está em casa né três pessoas
em casa ele aí sem querer se eu sei mas
sem querer se esquece trancar quanto o
planeta quem seu pai atacadão o cagão
cagando kagan pronto na sua casa você é
cagão vocês e cada um com seu pai vocês
e cada um possui não sei caibam com a
sua irmã secador com a sua mãe é normal
quem sabe podemos o caso não imaginando
e pega você carrega na escola ou servir
um cagão da escola então acho que é
melhor não caia na escola tá bom o carro
em junho perguntou a regra é clara pode
dar uns pegas no banheiro olha meu amigo
se eu fosse você e eu estávamos pega
através da sala eu já tava na sala pra
você que não sabe você não viveu direito
ainda maior por ter o existente na face
da terra até o meu amigo que a tenha 6
que a amiga falando da minha amiga aqui
mas às vezes você já pegou amigos
família na praça mundial matando ela
perguntou por que os russos ficam legais
com os nets no dia da prova a ameo jogos
e chama a esperteza tem aquela coisa uma
mão lava a outra e ardor batendo num
carro a bianca marques tentou porque o
seu lado os professores podem tocar na
sala de aula eo meu não quer você tem
que ter uma coisa o seu lado o professor
pode trocar pessoa pode tocar violão
sadia total a [ __ ] sabe alunos e não
porque a gente sempre a chamada tia da
menina do tempo professor porque a tia
da menina não passa a dever de casa né
meu jovem e nunca vai ver a tia da
menina financiou para evitar que alguns
cursos
o volante conhece tal acetabular massa
do curso com ou sem que você derrama o
leite do nescau a três metros de altura
vezes a massa molar do sol quando um
pouco fazer aqui dama da cidade caminha
manhã eu quero ver não tem a mulher
proporcionar alegria chega na segunda
ficou me dá comida obter bom de ver não
é tarefa é basicamente por isso era
muito obrigado eu quero você comente
aqui em baixo o que eu quero que você
comenta que embaixo quais são as coisas
que você mais odiava no seu tempo de
escola e é claro você tiver gostar do
vídeo você esteve e é claro se você
tiver o azar do vídeo você se divertir
um pouquinho da rahal filho assim que eu
não gostei de ser ajuda demais o canal
crescesse a primeira vez está assistindo
meu cíclica quem se inscreveu toda tiver
menos vai saber e é muito importante se
você está no seu facebook clique em
curtir tem que mostrar respeito a alguns
amigos que você faz e marca ele um
comentário aqui o vídeo mas o joão pedro
dá seu cavalo atingido massa é tendo
alcântara nunes ferreira marca pessoal
no comentário se você está no twitter é
muito importante você brt e brt no vídeo
o vídeo passo para mais pessoas você tá
no estado é lógico que ela só tinha eu
posso divulgando digital security a foto
tal e análise e viu e e até o próximo e
até o próximo vídeo respondendo pergunta
até o próximo vídeo é nóis se você está
assistindo agora porque eu tô operado
neste momento
e valeu que deseja melhoras aí é nóis em
pé